sérgio à gauche à la retape tomate est
là excuse moi ce serait pas serge
benamou ça va changer la vérité
mademoiselle il changera jamais ce toit
vérité mais la vérité et la vérité si je
mens histoire géographie et les sérieux
un bonheur d'une ode à tes parents
montrons ce n'est pas facile mais je
m'approche ya ait fana philosophie c'est
de la caisse de ton magasin c'est pas
ton argent de poche s'inquiète pas je
remette tout le monde se donne ma parole
que c'est la dernière fois que je bosse
comme un malade en temps c'est pour ça
que tu as encore en pyjama midi mois
[Musique]
d'autre part les ballots oui car bien
sûr
[Musique]
[ __ ] mais ya que moi qui bosse ici est
une cliente veut pas payer ces pénalités
de retard elle est où ta chute je vais
te montrer moi comment ça marche
à dix jours de retard alors tu travaille
à la poste
dans ce 3 passes et hacker ça ouais
ouais un patron faut bien que ça soit
prendre un appartement mais pourquoi
j'ai rencontré quelqu'un c'est ça je te
le dis tout de suite c'est pas la peine
de compter sur nous je financerai pains
maison drop pour monfils
[Musique]
elle est bonne sa mère c'est pas sa mère
ah bon
g bâle avait la mine pauvre garçon va
vous auriez demandé une dispense pour
raisons médicales
je vous montre combien de points on
track l'amitié la famille
[Musique]
allam et commence le nikkei s'est
retournée comme une crêpe tout sur un
peu plus simple plan et sa mère j'ai
même cru qu'elle a laissé filer l'avancé
l'eau